and it's no secret doctors and nurses
have been facing extreme fatigue as we
near two years now into this pandemic
yeah we told you about those longer wait
times in emergency rooms last night now
we are seeing another issue an
unprecedented demand in telemedicine
victoria saha joining us now live in
studio with a look at that growing
problem victoria
these are just the wait times are right
now at our local emergency rooms
although they may not seem too extreme
it's just another part of the problem we
see patients in emergency rooms that
don't need to be in there or patients
utilizing telehealth medicine when they
should actually be seeing a doctor in
person
the thought of communicating with your
doctor from the comfort of your home
sounds very enticing but that
convenience has led to doctors now
feeling what they're calling zoom
fatigue i'm swamped with patients at all
times it's really a nonstop influx of
patients dr alexandria lightning owns
her own medical practice after working
40 hours a week seeing in-person
patients she adds on an additional 30
hours of tele-health they stay
consistently every 20 minutes somebody
else booking an appointment she sees up
to 10 telehealth patients a night
there's no room to stop dr lightning
says a majority of her telehealth
patients have conditions that warrant
them to come in person to her office so
she can examine them fully we want to be
able to use all our senses and resources
that we have to treat the patient and
that really is best fit with an
in-person visit mental health
professionals are also dealing with an
overload in telehealth patients in most
cases we are
kind of packed to the brim lakisha
oliver a clinician with solutions of
change says the pandemic has caused a
lot of mental health needs and most
therapists are doing their best to
accommodate we also have to think of the
mental well-being of the clinicians and
so
there are people who are overloaded
now there are solutions to this dr
lightning says we can help take off some
of the load on local emergency rooms and
telehealth professionals if we are set
up with a primary care physician that
way conditions don't worsen and lead to
a visit to the er telehealth is best for
simpler needs such as a prescription
refill as for seeking mental health help
there could be a long wait list but
oliver says in the meantime joining a
support group could be your next avenue
denise
the